bonsoir
bonsoir bon je le disais il y a déjà une
enquête au sujet de ces posts tous ces
présumés pas de police chinois dans
l'ouest du pays voici qu'il y a une
enquête dans l'est d'abord est-ce que ça
vous surprend
du tout on sait très bien que les
l'ingérences Chinoises a été mentionnées
et on parle en 2013 de rituel Fab qui
était à ce moment-là le directeur du
Service canadien renseignement de
sécurité en comité parlementaire avait
indiqué que effectivement le service
penchait sur l'ingérance chinoise qui se
déroulait à l'intérieur du pays mais là
on est rendu dix ans plus tard et les
autorités chinoises sont d'autant plus
agressives qu'il était dans le passé le
Président je suis zimping en Chine en
2014 instaurer un projet qui s'appelle
le projet Fox Hunt et ce projet-là était
le but premier de ça c'était de aller
vers l'étranger et d'essayer de
rapatrier les ressortissants chinois qui
étaient soupçonnés de corruption ou de
fraude mais on a élargi ça pour inclure
aussi les citoyens chinois qui se
prononça contre le régime en place à
Pékin donc dans tout cette volatile là
sacrée quand même
un volet d'enquête qui très très
compliqué pour les autorités canadiennes
bon alors il faut comprendre que ce
qu'on en sait puis il y a eu des
rapports d'autres organismes la Chine
aurait installé dans une cinquantaine de
pays ces espèces de satellite sous le
couvert d'agence culturel ou agence de
voyage ou agence pour venir en aide ou
ressortissants chinois etc et on utilise
ça pour installer des espions entre
guillemets ou en tout cas des Chinois
qui vont s'assurer qu'il y a pas de qui
rien qui dépasse il y a pas de
propagande contre leur gouvernement etc
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça des
postes de police
utilise l'Arsenal à leur disposition
incluant l'intimidation il y a
d'ailleurs un
ressortissant chinois avant couvert qui
lui s'est prononcé contre le régime et
immédiatement à travers les médias
sociaux il y a des gens qui ont publié
son numéro de téléphone son adresse et
ont invité les citoyens chinois qui est
en désaccords de communiquer avec lui et
d'en faire le plus possible pour créer
du harcèlement contre l'individus comme
tel voici un type d'action qui est
préconisé par ces soi-disant postes de
police là mais il faut comprendre que si
aux États-Unis le FBI depuis 2020 à
effectuer 16 arrestations en relation
avec des gens qui opérait à l'intérieur
de poste de police similaire en sol
américain donc tout ça pour dire que il
ne faut pas être naïf et la GRC a
clairement démontré leur intention
d'essayer d'obtenir le plus de
renseignements possible pour mettre un
terme à ce type d'activité là en sol
canadien est-ce qu'on est bien équipé au
Canada ce que la GRC bien équipé pour
infiltrer ces milieux là et pour savoir
qui fait quel travail dans ces postes de
police
c'est très difficile monsieur roi
puisque
c'est qu'il y a quand même une espèce de
de
crainte de la part des citoyens chinois
ici parce qu'évidemment comme l'agent de
la GRC le mentionner un peu plus tôt
dans votre émission il y a de
l'assimilation qui peut être fait en
seul chinois contre les familles de ces
jeux-là qui demeurent en sols canadien
donc tout ça crée une dynamique très
difficile pour les policiers afin
d'effectuer leur enquête et de s'assurer
d'accumuler suffisamment de preuves pour
déposer les chefs d'accusation devant
les tribunaux canadiens très très
difficile est-ce qu'on doit en faire
plus ce bordel le gouvernement canadien
la police est-ce qu'on doit en faire
plus devant ces tentacules chinoises là
que l'on voit bon soit effort tentative
d'ingérence dans le processus électoral
soit intimidation auprès de
ressortissants chinois
le gouverneur aurait tendance et devrait
regarder un peu ce qui s'est déroulé en
Australie alors que l'Australie a mis en
place un cadre législatif qui permet à
ce moment-là aux enquêteurs d'avoir les
outils nécessaires pour pouvoir déposer
les chefs d'accusation donc possiblement
le gouvernement Canadien devrait se
tourner du côté de l'Australie pour
examiner ce qui s'est fait là-bas pour
justement donner des outillages
nécessaires aux autorités canadiennes
pour pouvoir effectuer des arrestations
et mettre encore une fois un terme à ce
type d'activité là en soit le Canadien
vous le dites pas comme ça mais c'est un
peu comme si vous disiez il faut un peu
sortir de la naïveté là peut-être un peu
plus agressif vous avez la Chine
définitivement vous vous rappelez des
deux scientistes qui ont été sortis
littéralement d'un laboratoire à
Winnipeg de ce 4 ans la GRC enquête
encore sur ce dossier là donc c'est des
dossiers d'enquête à longue Alain et on
a pour les policiers c'est un enquête
qui est quand même très difficile donc
la nécessité d'avoir un outil âge
nécessaire pour pouvoir mener ce type
d'enquête là à bon port on est rendu là
il y a aussi cet employé d'Hydro-Québec
qui a été arrêté par la GRC
accusée d'espionnage on verra la suite
en cours Pierre-Yves bourduat sous
commissaire à la retraite de la
Gendarmerie royale du Canada merci
ça me fait plaisir bonne fin de journée
au revoir